so to do that I want to draw your
attention back to this graph I should do
I don't know if you ran out of time to
do it but we want to think about this
because it has some implications for the
second rule okay so why do things to the
form now I wondered you have a picture
what this looks like in your mind before
we draw it I want to do some work with
it okay so if we were to find do the
real things right here like it if we
wanted to say final stationary points
okay the term in their nature here's
what you might do you would say the
first derivative is equal to 4x cubed
right so you would conclude from that
okay that looks like it's a stationary
point at x equals 0 and correspondingly
Y goes 0 as well at the origin you've
got a stationary point okay but then you
want to determine if a chalk okay we
just learned that we can use we could
test on either side that would work but
we can use the secondary that'll be cool
and I'll be quicker in some cases right
and this is one of the functions where
as it gets as you differentiate more it
gets simpler because it's not a fraction
right so cool let's do this second
derivative is just 12x squared and then
something weird is happening so we can
see that there's a stationary point at
the origin okay but at the origin what
happens to the second derivative hmm
because we were thinking okay if it's a
station point should be like concave up
or concave down and that will tell us if
it's a max or a min right but something
else is going on at the origin the
second derivative is what is just zero
right so what does that tell us
this tells us gradient this tells us
concavity so this is saying this the
concavity at the origin so what does
this thing look like okay well let me
draw it for you if you join x squared
before you know parabolas are fine okay
X to the 4 if you actually plot some
points what I was like is very similar
x squared but it's a it looks like it's
put on a few pounds because it sits at
the bottom it's really really fat you
can zoom in and it doesn't just go down
and lift off okay it actually seems to
stay down there for a little while or at
least longer than that square okay so
what does that mean
you've got nerve cavity at the origin
okay so what is this it's not a point of
inflection is it because if you're
looking at look at the whole thing okay
how would you describe its cavity
concave up and then concave up okay yeah
that's right it's it's there's no change
in cook happy okay so even though we
expect you remember we looked up it's
the second derivative is zero so usually
we would expect a point of inflection
okay but in this case and you can see it
by testing it's not okay that's why I
was emphasizing yesterday right the
turning point occurs when dy/dx changes
sign
it's got again from positive to negative
or negative to positive okay a point of
inflection occurs when the second
derivative does the same okay and PR
there's no change okay it just stays
positive the whole way through
okay so now